hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game and as the title suggests a
very short one between Felix Langille
better known as xqc and Charlie who
doesn't have an official last name
rather I wasn't able to find one online
I did find one but it does seem to be a
nun confirmed one so I decided to skip
it out but on twitch he's known as moist
critical and on YouTube as penguin zero
and yeah it's a it's a very short game
so without further ado let's check it
out - many of you have requested it so I
decided to show it as part of this video
where we are going to discuss several
things so without further ado xqc opens
with E 4 we have E 5 from Charlie Knight
to have 3 by Felix and now Knight to c6
and d4 the Scotch is on the board we've
each capture sandy for n night capture
so nothing out of the ordinary here and
Bishop the c-5 not with a double attack
on the knight and here you could do a
lot of things for example Knight
captures on c6 is a very popular line
that that attacks the Queen and then you
can do a nice in-between move that
threatens checkmate and only after the
Queen defense can you pick up the night
here and the game just continues however
after this Bishop to c5 move Felix
played c3 defends the knight on d4 and
now comes Knight to f6 and this is a
this is one move that can often well can
often end in a very short game when when
players who are just starting out their
chests journey or playing and it is what
happened in this game here you wouldn't
usually continue with something like
Bishop to e3 and then the game continues
where the Queen is a bit suspicious on
on f6 however now Felix played the
knight captures on c6 here and he left
his F DuPont undefended
at which point Charlie just captured it
and delivered
checkmate so Queen captures on f2 is
checkmate and this is how this game
ended in six moves so very impressive
and Charlie was very impressed with with
himself he said that this must be some
sort of a record he was a he he inquired
as to what is it
you see the chat saying and so on so
what I'm showing this is well aside from
a lot of you are requesting it is
because I would also like to share with
you this article it's an article from
chess tech beyond the board and well it
it talks about a SPOC champs a good way
to promote chess or basically is it an
embarrassment for chess now here I'm
going to I'm going to read the entire
article now so for those of you who are
not interested in hearing that I will
also put just a link to it in the
description below if you prefer reading
but here we have views of David lada who
is the chief marketing and
communications officer at Viacom and
also that of Stephan Leffler who is the
features editor of chess death so one is
for POC champs as ways of promoting
chess and the other one is against it so
let's just briefly go through it so
chess that come runs a chess tournament
on Twitch between popular gamers and
streamers for feed a chief marketing and
communications officer David Lada POC
champs is the best chess promotion in
years chest the editor Stefan Lafleur
ass is it sees it as an embarrassment
for the contestants the world's biggest
chess platform and ultimately our games
so let's see some of the pros and cons
or so to say here David Lada says I am
very critical about how chess has
generally been promoted we have been
doing it all wrong all the time with
very few exceptions the inaugural chest
at calm Park champs is one of these
exceptions I hope it is here to stay our
chess is popular but the overall
popularity of the game doesn't pay
justice to the fantastic qualities that
chess possesses as a product I firmly
believe there is a huge untapped
potential I would go as far as the state
that we could double the size of the
currently existing chess community in
the medium term just with some hard work
in the right direction and with a little
bit of creativity
so our main sin is that chess people
tend not to think outside of the chess
board
they don't pay enough attention to the
world around them this little flaw is
inherent to our nature the game rewards
those who managed to isolate them
themselves but this bad trait is
reflected in how the chess world is
structured and how
functions also he says purely purely
promotional activities are marginalized
you give 10 K probably $10,000 or 10,000
euros doesn't really matter to the
average chess organizer to improve his
tournament and he will spend it on
hiring two more 2,600 players like this
is going to make a difference also he
says that if you give him a million he
will organize ten tournaments in exactly
the same way with a hundred thousand
dollars or euros in prizes each we live
in perpetual endogamy repeating
ourselves almost no one is inventing in
reaching out to new audiences there are
very few strategic plans in place to
expand and bring new players to the game
this is where Park champs fit the
initiative just ticks all the boxes you
take a bunch of popular variety
streamers with a combined audience of 15
million subscribers and you throw a
chess challenge at them I believe some
of these guys actually learn to play
during the early weeks of the lockdown
is it silly yes are we making a show out
of the absolute beginners blundering
pieces yes
so what also he says another common
scene is our chess community in our
chess community is that we take
ourselves too seriously punk pogchamp
ziz not disrespecting chess but quite
the opposite - the whole thing sends a
message to a huge audience showing how
easy it is to learn the game but how
difficult it is to master it and it
demonstrates that chess can be fun from
minute one I am just eyeballing from the
perspective of a former business person
but this initiative probably awakens a
curiosity about chess in two or three
million people 1 million of them may
become occasional players and maybe
around 250,000 of them will turn into
hardcore fans new chess consumers will
who will contribute towards the chest
economy by taking chess lessons
participating in open tournaments and
buying chess books also I remember when
my friend Antonio rowdy shot a matter
that's me I started his youtube channel
his rating is around 1950 2000 and he
commentates chess games for an audience
up to that level I recall hearing some
demeaning comments from grandmasters at
a time but the skepticism vanished when
the number of his subscribers surpassed
anything seen before
before he has now 671 thousand followers
and the growing Antonia has probably
brought more people more new people to
the game than many super gyms together
and we all benefit from his work in
direct and indirect ways we need more
Park champs more and more other matters
we need a celebrity tournaments hand and
brain events Pro based exhibitions we
need more banter blitz and more
commentators like pepper cuenca we need
corporate championship singers like
hygge photographers like Leonard Otis
artists like Maria who veena and global
chess festivals like Judith polgár's
just connects us we probably can live
without one more 2,700 round-robin
tournament the only thing that bugs me
about Park champs is that the idea did
not occur to me before so this is
basically David's view of the whole
matter regarding the pogchamp so now
we're gonna check out Stefan's view he
says Bob and Danny commentators of many
world-class events cannot help laughing
a simple night check pics of the Queen
he's referring to the game
loosely one of the streamers were was
playing in the park champ championship a
simple night check picks up the Queen
will foolishly see it if it's not
pronounced fully apology apologies for
that I do not know how it's pronounced
her hand moves towards the night but she
picks up a pawn next to it eyes are
rolling her opponent doesn't use the
chance to save his queen and instead
continues with an attack on the knight
prompted this way firstly moves the
knight and gives the check she still
hasn't seen that it Nets her the Queen
until she bursts out what F word the
genius she is then falls by fool is one
of the 16 beginners at chess who
happened to be famous and often twitch
to warrant an invitation on Park champs
chest that com spends fifty thousand
dollars in prize money and probably a
similar amount on commentators and
transmissions the viewer numbers may be
worth the investment however and this is
something that well that is basically
the the whole theme of this video the
real price the world the biggest chess
platform is paying is its reputation
something I'm very interested if you
guys agree on regular users are dismayed
that the pot a Patzer Bonanza has taken
center stage as if their favorite
platform told them who cares for a match
between Carlson and our onion when you
can see foolishly right also he says
pork champs remind me reminds me of I'm
a celebrity get me out of here which was
not the lowest point but the emblematic
format of trash TV see list see list
celebrities embarrass themselves for
attention publicity and a handful of
cash
the trouble with chess is that it takes
years of play and study until you
occasionally produce a game that is
worth seeing
letting beginners play for an audience
is something one should never do if
chess comm wanted to do a show with
gamers and streamers instead of
presenting them as fools they should
have been respected as the learners they
are at chess they could have competed at
mini games solved puzzle rush exercises
of the simple simple variety and showed
their team skills at hand and brain and
only in the end of the show they would
play a normal chess game one against one
not on the practical but boring user
interface of the chess platform but in a
cool game fight the display as gamers
and their fan audiences are used to do
so that's it for the article you've
heard David's view of the of the matter
and also Stefan's view of the matter so
I'm very much interested in to which
view are you leaning towards I know most
of you guys are silent silent Watchers
on the channel but maybe for this video
you can make an exception and if you
don't really feel like typing anything
all that much you can just write who
you're you know leaning towards more and
yeah that's basically basically the
question is are we satisfied with just
the way it is without bringing more
people to the game or do we do we want
more people to the game because on one
side you have me some random dude here
from Croatia analyzing Elite Grandmaster
games and on the other hand you have
super grandmasters analyzing games
played by maybe 16 to 18 hundred euro
players and I don't know it's it's a
tricky it's a tricky question because
for example if someone only knows the
moves of the game he doesn't know much
more and he sees the game played between
let's say since Stefan already mentioned
car across an errand and if he sees a
game played between Carlsen our onion
analyzed by let's say three super
grandmasters basically all he's gonna
hear is blah blah blah
and I don't think he's gonna be all that
much interested in becoming a chess
player or taking up chess or investing
any time in learning chess at all and on
the other hand when he sees a foosley
blundering I would say three pieces in
one move and that'd be presented as a
positive experience you know everyone is
laughing everyone is enjoying themselves
that person might decide to take up
chess invest more time in it and well
maybe even become a chess player with
time so you know both I would say for
for getting more people to the game like
that it suggests that we were to maybe
double the existing Church just based
off players pogchamp sigh I believe is
definitely the way to go and it's yeah
it's it's a very interesting article and
a very interesting question
I for one side would dive it on this one
since it's something I've been doing for
forever and well I'm just always up for
bringing more people to the game I don't
think it disrespects the game or that
it's an embarrassment for chests people
who like I haven't been following even
though a lot of people follow POC champs
I didn't really show any games from
pogchamp aside from that one that boy
boy played against Nate Hill as I was a
where I was showing games from the
clutch just international and from other
bigger events so of course when there's
like a game between Carlson and Oregon
as that we've already used that
expression I will of course show that
one first but it doesn't mean I'm not
interested in this and will not show
this and yeah I just think since I'm not
an elite player me me showing a game
between Carlson and Oregon is more
enjoyable for beginners than someone who
maybe is trying to take up chest then
when a super Grand Master does it as
their commentary is you know far more
well the detailed and sophisticated than
mine but yeah basically that's what I
wanted to ask you guys who do you lean
towards the David or Stephane
you know doo doo comment and yeah that's
it that's basically it for this video I
do I do hope you enjoyed this sex move
game this charlie brilliance and that
you've enjoyed my my reading skills
which not all that impressive but you
know it did take me a while and yeah
also I would like to thank very much
Majumdar Nigel Herman's Suleiman sorte
Stephen Thurman and Russell light for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of anything what
happens in the chest world checking up
in your wonderful suggestions and so on
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day